lawyers are constrained by what they can  say  about the facts of a case by court rule  and state bar rules  the police aren't  the police and arm of the district  attorney has released  what they say are facts  i have been doing this for 40 years and  i can tell each and every one of you  that i have had multiple experiences  where the facts that were presented at  the outset of the case  turned out not to be the facts  so that's why i keep saying  please don't prejudge  let us do our work in the courtroom the  state the prosecutor will do theirs and  that's when the facts will be determined  and i really appreciate everybody  understanding that and not prejudging  this i appreciate it i'm not going to  answer any questions because as i say  i'm not allowed to discuss the facts i  hope everybody has a good day mr